adam wainwright waiting for his
teammates and now ready to take them out
racing out to the pitchers mound and
away we go here for game number one
against the new york mets
the one-two pitch
he struck him out 75 miles an hour
[Applause]
popped up
o'neal coming on and he'll make the
catch let's go one two three good start
for wayne oh cardinals coming up in the
whole half of the first well there's
lucasy right there his toyota numbers as
i said on the open this will be his
third start fourth appearance
and the 3-2 is whacked out to right and
that ball will get down edmond on his
way to second he'll race for third it'll
be a lead off triple tommy edmond
conforto
had trouble picking it up it's a triple
for tommy edmond
that's the second lead-off triple for
tommy edmond this year
here's dylan carlson with a runner at
third base
and carlson hits it down the right field
line that's slicing into the corner the
catch is made by conforto edmond will
score and it's one to nothing saint
louis here in the first
and the sure hit on the ground nice play
mcneal he leads lyndor to the bag and
the turn for the double play brilliantly
done they did it in the first inning
last night and mcneil starts another
4-6-3 gem
leading lindor perfectly to start the
double play and the cardinals settle for
one
boy alonzo's last time up last night he
banged a three run
double to right center
[Music]
hits this one out to right field slicing
toward the line for carlson but it drops
in for a hit alonzo on his way to second
and carlson's throw is too late so pete
again goes to right and again winds up
with a two base hit although not struck
as ferociously as the one last night
inside corner and he struck him out that
strikeout number one thousand at busch
stadium for adam wainwright it's an
incredible milestone right there a
thousand strikeouts at busch stadium
this is a perfectly located pitch 91
front door
brings it back
man that's pretty
been hitting in some hard luck but there
was less hard luck last night
and with nemo not available tonight he
gets another start he lines one into
center field he's got another hit alonzo
held up he goes to third he'll stop
there
feed was just making sure now down to
second base goes pilar as they missed
the cut-off man so the mets were
aggressive last night with vr stealing a
run this time pillar takes an extra base
as bader misses the cut-off man so now
two in scoring position and they are
going to walk wow are intentionally the
pitch to tomas nida in the second inning
of a one-nothing game
i'll tell you what that is i mean i know
nito hasn't played very much and he's a
double play threat but that is that's a
little shocking by the way this one
turns out
neato and that force is in a run how
about that
they walk vr to load the bases and
wainwright's first pitch hits him in the
elbow guard on the mets tie the game
only the second time in his career he's
hit a batter with the bases loaded the
first time came 14 years ago he hit
russell martin
when he was with the dodgers for the
pitch to force in a run in 2007
3-2
and he walked him to force in another
run
2-1 new york
a bases loaded hit by pitch and now a
bases loaded walk and the mets stroll
their way to the lead
the 1-2 pitch
he got him
lindor strikes out for the second time
tonight
wainwright strikes out three in the
inning and four so far tonight
3-1 pitch
watched
back-to-back days for vader he loves
hitting those lefties
he loves it
2-2
and this one's driven to left-center and
that'll go to the gap
cut off by
bader conforto to third and alonso dives
in safely at second he is now doubled
again
second double of the night for pete in
his fourth in the last three games
and the mets have second and third and
nobody out
curveball hit on the ground down to
first a run will score goldschmidt makes
the play on smith but it's a doubly
productive out as conforto comes in with
a lead run and alonso gets to third
so dom smith drives in his ninth run of
the year and the mets are back in front
three to two and that's it in the air to
center field hit pretty well boehner
going back to the warning track back at
the wall it's out of here
kevin pillar strikes again
his second home run is ahmed his second
and two nights a 2-1 shot for pillar
and now the mets lead it 5-2
the 2-2
base hit into right
and goldie hits it off the end of the
bat pilar racing in diving for it did he
come up with it no it gets by him and
carlson will wind up at
third instead the cardinals have runners
at the corners and nolan arenado this is
going to go from questionable foul ball
to souvenir you're calling it yeah
way back
[Applause]
2-1
right center
off the top of the wall
and the young trots into second
oh we were close
the young the go ahead run at second
base and the first pitch to o'neill is
hit hard in the left field that's a base
hit paul de young rounds third he's
headed home and he's gonna score the
cardinals are gonna take the lead five
to four and tyler o'neill gets to second
base a hustling double
and the cardinals have taken the lead
six to five
tommy edmond base hit
off the sidewall
thinking too
with his speed no doubt
top of the lineup one run game alex
reyes in here we go
again this is how you set it up right
hand the ball over to your best arm the
chevy call of the bullpen is alex reyes
13 games this season
doesn't give up and uh given up a run
yet and
the 1-1
should be out number two shallow center
bader coming on
two away
the final hope for the mets
pete alonso
[Applause]
well not a bad final hope to have for
the mets a couple of doubles and a
single in the ball game so far
[Applause]
room on the right side and the lights
have gone out here at the ball park
i'm not sure i've ever seen this before
i have
and the time that it took place many
years ago it takes
a little three seconds
there we go
the led lights are different than what
we had before
those other ones had to ramp up that's
right so we were told that if this
happened
they could pop right back on
and that's what just took place
3-1 coming
and he missed ball four
and now the mets of the tying and go
ahead runs on base and dom smith coming
up
3-2 pitch
fly ball
left field this will do it o'neal there
makes the catch and the cardinals hold
on for a 6-5 win
st louis
is now five games above the 500 mark